>> Tucker: THANKS SO MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
AS YOU JUST HEARD OF, PAINFUL
ATTACKS ON THE PRO-LIFE MOVEMENT
ARE NOW NORMAL.
YOU JUST HEARD WHAT HAPPENED IN
DOWNTOWN PHILADELPHIA WITH THE
PENNSYLVANIA REPRESENTATIVE.
HERE IS PART OF IT.
>> HELLO EVERYONE,
REPRESENTATIVE BRIAN SIMS HERE
AND I'M OUTSIDE OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
THERE'S A BUNCH OF
PSEUDO-CHRISTIAN PROTESTERS WHO
ARE SHAMING YOUNG GIRLS.
I HAVE $100 TO ANYONE WHO WILL
IDENTIFY ANY OF THESE THREE.
I WILL DONATE IT TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
THREE WHITE PEOPLE STANDING
OUTSIDE AND SHAMING PEOPLE.
THERE'S NOTHING CHRISTIAN ABOUT
WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
>> Tucker: TODAY PRO-LIFE
ACTIVIST HELD A RALLY OUTSIDE OF
THAT SAME PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN
RESPONSE TO THAT BEHAVIOR.
YOUR STORY WAS TOLD IN A RECENT
FILM "UNPLANNED."
OF COURSE, IS IT OUR IMAGINATION
OR IS THE REACTION TO
ANTIABORTION ACTIVISM INCLUDING
PRAYER TURNING VIOLENT?
BUT THEY ARE NOT WILLING TO COME
OUT AND TALK ABOUT THIS BEHAVIO
BEHAVIOR.
NOBODY FROM THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO STAND UP FOR WOMEN,
NOBODY IS COMING OUT AND
CONDEMNING THIS BEHAVIOR.
IT JUST SORT OF GOES UNCHECKED.
IT GOES WITHOUT NOTICE AND
CONSEQUENCES.
THERE WERE A THOUSAND OTHER
PRO-LIFERS THAT WERE THERE TODAY
TO SAY, THIS IS ENOUGH.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE BELIEVED,
NOT HARASSED, WE ARE OUT THERE
AND THIS IS WITHIN THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS TO DO SO.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU THINK
IS DRIVING THIS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ARGUING FOR ABORTION.
IN SOME CASES POST LIABILITY AND
LATE-TERM ABORTION.
NOT ONLY ARE THEY ASHAMED, BUT
THEY WANT TO HURT ANYONE WHO
DISAGREES.
WHERE DOES THAT COME FROM?
>> I THINK IT'S A COUPLE THINGS.
I THINK RIGHT NOW ABORTION
SUPPORTERS ARE FEELING THE HEAT.
FEELING THE PRESSURE.
WE HAVE THESE HEARTBEAT BILLS
BEING SIGNED ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, PRO-LIFE MAJORS TAKING
PLACE, AND NOW WE HAVE A
SUPREME COURT THAT IS BEING SET
UP TO OVERTURN ROE V. WADE AND
IN SOME WAYS IT'S A RESPONSE TO
THE SORT OF IMPENDING DOOM THAT
THEY FEEL THAT ROLE MIGHT ONE
DAY BE ACTUALLY OVERTURNED.
BUT I THINK ALSO, WE'VE GOT OVER
60 MILLION ABORTIONS ON THE
BOOKS RECORDED SINCE ROE WAS
PASSED IN 1973.
AND WE ARE DEALING WITH A GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY WOUNDED.
THEY ARE VERY HURT AND THEY NEED
TO REALLY JUSTIFY THEIR OWN
ACTIONS.
A LOT OF TIMES THAT HURT COMES
ACROSS AS ANGER AND THEY DON'T
SEE THE DIFFERENCE.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHEN YOU KNOW YOU ARE WRONG,
THAT IS WHEN YOU ARE THE MOST